- I had a hard time
believing it when I actually,
I like I need to go and
actually read the legislation.
I went in and read it
and it did just that
to somehow believe
that it is a good thing
to remove all references
of mother and father,
brother and sister, son and
daughter from essentially
the administration of the house
from the legislative rules.
Not only does it not make sense,
it is a dangerous step
towards undermining,
who we are and the
existence of men and women.
(corporate music)
- Joining me today
is an army veteran,
a former democratic US
presidential candidate
and now former
Congresswoman, Tulsi Gabbard.
Welcome back to
the "Rubin Report."
- Hey, good to see
you, Dave, always.
- So there's obviously
a ton to talk about here
and a lot of stuff happening
right now as we tape this,
but first off do I
have to refer to you
as former Congresswoman?
Do you keep being called
Congresswoman forever?
How does that work?
Like when when you're
mayor they always call you
Mr. Mayor or Mr. President,
are you Congresswoman
Tulsi forever,
even though you've stepped away?
- I think so, but I don't
know the answer to that.
My former staff asked
me that yesterday,
I was like, you know what?
I actually don't know
the answer to that
but Tulsi is always great.
- Tulsi will work.
Okay, so look, we're
taping this right now
as the Capitol is
literally being stormed.
I mean, that is
happening right now.
I know you were seeing it
right before we started
just as I was.
I wasn't planning
on starting here
but what do you make of
what's going on right now?
- I mean, it's heartbreaking
to see this happening
at our nation's capital,
but it is also indicative.
This is a symptom of much
deeper issues and challenges
that have been stewing
for a long time.
And a lot, especially as of
late, over this last year
where this conflict culture
that we have seen growing
in our society, whether it's
online and now it's being
embodied or actioned offline,
it results in
something like this.
And so you've got to look at
what's driving this,
what's fueling it.
You can look at politicians,
political leaders,
who are more
interested in fueling
and yeah fueling
divisiveness, riling people up
for their own personal
or political benefit.
You see the media doing
the same thing for ratings.
You see these big
tech monopolies
in Facebook using
algorithms and social media
to continue to push and push
and put fuel on the flames
of this divisiveness.
Well, you see what is
happening here today
at the United States
Capitol before our very eyes
is the manifestation of that.
That is the symptom of
these deeper problems.
And from a leadership
perspective,
I think this is where
you've got to look
to the kind of leadership
we need but don't have
in this country right now.
Which is leadership that puts
the wellbeing of the people
and country before themselves,
before political power,
before their selfish ambition.
- Are you kind of
shocked as someone
that was in the government that
just not only our leadership
in terms of government,
but our leadership
sort of across the board,
our academic leadership,
our intellectual leadership,
there's podcasters
and stuff like that, but that
we don't have sort of like
a trusted group
of people anymore
that kind of bring us
together across the board?
It almost just simply
doesn't exist anymore.
- I think that's right.
And I think that it's become
such a segmented thing
where you have whether it's
a political leadership,
those in the media or those a
new media or whatever it is,
you have these these
quote unquote influencers
that are only speaking to
their segment of people
who agree with them or
believe the same things
that they believe.
And there's no exposure,
real civil discourse
or dialogue to people who
might have different views,
different opinions,
different beliefs,
different political positions.
And I think it's not
only not a good thing
for our country, but I
think also contributes
especially when you're
using this divisive rhetoric
and language that can help fuel
those who then get
riled up and say,
oh, actually, you know what?
I'm gonna go take action on
this because those people,
they are my enemy.
That's the dangerous thing.
- So does this what's
happening right now
and then we'll move on
to some other stuff.
Does it sort of feel
like this was inevitable
in a weird way?
Like once I started
seeing it this morning,
it was just kinda like, oh yeah,
of course this is exactly
what was gonna happen.
And in a weird way, it's
almost like we all deserve it
for being part of it
or something like that.
- Well, I was, oh
gosh, months ago,
months ago was maybe one
of a few people who warned
of a civil war if we continue
down the path that we are on.
And I think that what
we are seeing now
with this divisiveness that
exists very much online
now being translated into
action further points
in that direction.
Unless we, as a country
do something about it.
We as the American people,
we as leaders in this country,
unless we shift course
and start leading
for the interest of the public,
the American people,
servant leadership,
leaders who are in
positions of power
whether they're elected
or not elected saying,
I am here to serve this
country and the American people
not my party, not my
political interests,
not my political ambition
or selfish, money.
Whatever that selfish
driver may be,
we need servant leaders
in place leading
with what we in
Hawaii call Aloha.
You and I have talked
about this before.
Aloha is saying,
hey, I respect you.
I open my heart and I love
you as a fellow person
as a child of God,
as a fellow American.
And whether we agree or
disagree on different issues,
whether we come from
different backgrounds or not,
we've gotta be able to
come together on this
shared common ground and
work for the betterment
and the wellbeing
of the country.
And I think just one last--
- [Dave] So what do you think,
- I was just gonna say one
last note on the danger
of what we are seeing
playing out today
is this normalization of
violence where violence
and a lot of the
riots that we've seen
over the last year
are occurring.
That violence is somehow okay
if it aligns with your view
of what these people are,
quote unquote fighting for.
And that's, that's a
very dangerous thing
because when I say
leading with Aloha,
I don't mean just,
okay we're just gonna sit
back and not do anything.
Leading with Aloha means
standing up and fighting
for what is right but doing
so within the construct
of the institutions that
we have in this country.
For example, if
you are concerned
about the legitimacy and the
integrity of our elections,
take action to do something.
I introduced a bill called
The Securing America's
Election Act that if
our country's leaders
had passed would have prevented
a lot of the the angst
that people are feeling
and seeing right now
with this election saying
that you have to
have a paper trail.
You have to have an
auditable paper backup
for any electronic system.
So that there's no doubt
or question in mind
if there has been a hack attempt
or some attempt to manipulate
our votes as voters.
If all of these
people in Congress,
Democrat and Republican had
taken that issue seriously
and passed that legislation,
those who are now saying,
hey, we have to
stand up for the...
Why don't you do
something about it before?
We do need to stand up and
fight for the well-being
of this country, stand
up for our constitution,
uphold it but we need
to do it in a way
that is constructive and
within the institutions
that have been set up in this
society, that is America.
- So I have no doubt that
probably every single person
watching this right now
is agreeing with you
and going, okay,
that all makes sense.
I'm on board.
So Tulsi why'd you get out?
Like you're exactly
what we need, right?
Like, I mean, I've tweeted
it a million times.
If Tulsi Gabbard was the
future of the democratic party,
I could honestly consider
myself a Democrat.
I can't do that anymore.
I don't consider
myself a Republican
but what you just said
there, I think most people
agree with, yet at the same
time you are getting out.
So tell me about that.
- I had to make
a decision, Dave.
And I had to make a decision,
I made this decision
last fall of 2019
as I was campaigning
for president.
It was a frankly, a
practical decision
where I could not both run
for reelection to Congress
and continue running for
president at the same time.
And I made the decision
to run for president.
It was a very serious decision
that was well thought through.
And I made the decision
to continue that campaign
for the presidency because
of the grave issues
that I was raising
in that campaign
and the kind of change in
leadership that I really believe
our country needs.
So I'm gonna continue to fight.
I may not be in Congress
anymore as of a few days ago
but I'm gonna continue
to advocate for freedom.
I'm gonna continue to advocate
for common sense solutions
in our society and
in our government.
And to continue to bring the
truth to the conversations
that we as a country
should be having.
- So speaking of the truth,
I mean, I'm just putting
my cards on the table.
I find you to be
one of the last,
I guess you're not
a politician anymore
but one of the last, somewhat
honest politicians, right?
I sense that you're
really trying to do
something decent here.
Can you just talk
about what it was like
to go through the
democratic machine
during the primary process and
go through the media machine
during that, the way
the media treated you
and that insane comment
that Hillary made about you,
and that little tussle that
you got in with Kamala,
all of those things.
While it was like, I was
seeing so many people online
that were like, I can't
be a Democrat anymore
but I kinda like her,
that's the direction.
And yet the party, the way the
party in effect treated you.
- Yeah, we could do a
whole show just on this.
But I'll point to--
- Come on get on your
(indistinct), let's go.
- A couple of the
major takeaways
that I had from
that experience is,
the danger and the threat
that is posed to our democracy
by the power of our political
parties, both of them.
And the power that
the media has.
A lot of people talk about
needing to reform our money
in politics and make sure
that it's more transparent.
And I agree with a lot
of all those things,
they are necessary
but nobody points to
the effect that the media has
and the billions of
dollars that that exposure,
that narrative that
they're pushing is worth
and how they are filtering
what kind of information
voters are getting access to.
I'll throw big tech
in with this as well,
because they're the
Google, Facebook,
they're doing the exact
same thing and deciding,
hey this is,
this or these are the candidates
who we want you to hear from.
Here's the narrative that
we want you to hear or see.
And in my case, they
chose their narrative.
They chose their candidates
and ultimately they decided
that they didn't want
voters to hear from me.
- But who is they?
'Cause I feel like it
always comes down to this.
Like certain people
will be like,
okay, it's the Clinton machine
that runs the democratic party
or maybe that's
kind of crumbling,
now it's more the Obama machine.
Like when you say that,
like that the party
didn't want you there,
in effect or big tech,
all those pieces,
like who is they, do you think?
People ask me this all the time.
I don't know that anyone
has a good answer.
- Ultimately it is
whether it's the people
who hold these positions
of power, literally.
The heads of these
media institutions,
these for-profit corporations
who are supposedly
generating news.
But also it's both the people
who are in charge
of political parties
but also the people who are
maybe more institutional people.
Like the Clintons, for example.
I came and spoke the truth
about a lot of different issues
from our foreign policy
and how destructive
this foreign policy
has been largely led by
people like Hillary
Clinton and others,
and the cost that it has
carried both to soldiers
and friends and veterans who I
know and who I've served with
but also to every
single American.
Bringing the truth and
calling out big tech,
calling out the media.
This is something that they
felt they didn't want to happen.
And so those two areas
really take away the opportunity
whether you're talking
about the power
the political parties
have through the money
that they're able to raise,
unlimited amounts
of money essentially
and leverage those dollars
to pressure individuals,
members of Congress,
state political parties,
to do what they want,
as well as the power
that the media has.
These are the things that
are getting in the way
of the American people
being able to get the truth
and to be shown, hey,
here are the choices
that you have to vote
for in this election.
Let's have a fair hearing
of what they stand for,
what kind of
leadership they bring,
the qualifications,
experience that they bring,
what kind of judgment
they'll exercise.
Frankly, that's not happening.
That's not happening
in our election.
- So speaking of
the big tech thing,
are you still involved in
that lawsuit with YouTube?
- With Google, no.
We ended up having
to drop the lawsuit.
Or actually, no, I
think with that one,
I've been involved
in a couple here.
I think the Google lawsuit,
a judge did not
rule in our favor.
So that's something
that legislatively
I've continued to push
through either abolishing
or reforming section 230,
so that big tech monopolies
like Google and Facebook,
do not have this legal
immunity that allows them
to do whatever they
want essentially
and defying the whole purpose of
what section 230
was created for.
Which was to say, hey,
you know, let's have fair
and neutral platforms online
for people to kind of have
this public square.
Google and Facebook and
others have taken that
and abused it and have turned
themselves into publishers
by picking and choosing what
information those online
actually get to see
and sequestering or
censoring others,
you know all about this.
But they're not held
to the same standard
that the New York
Times is held to,
where New York Times picks
and chooses what stories,
what letters to the editor
what op-eds they choose
because they are publishers.
These big tech monopolies
are acting as publishers
but they're not held to
the same legal standard
that any other
publisher is held to.
And those were the
reforms that I was pushing
through my legislation.
- Do you sense
though that the ship
has probably just
sailed on that?
I mean, Trump was sort
of trying to do it
and the Republicans were
always threatening about it
but they don't,
and having hearings
but they just
never did anything.
Do you sense that there's
just no reason at this point?
- I don't think we should
give, I don't think
we can give up this fight.
Because there's so
much at stake here.
Social media has become
such a part of so
many people's lives.
And as we are seeing here today,
what is happening at
the Capitol where,
I know the updates
are still coming in,
but before we started,
I saw there was at
least one person shot,
multiple Capitol police
have been injured.
The algorithms that the social
media companies are using
to intentionally manipulate
and control the information
that their users are getting,
has a direct role to play
in inciting this kind of
frankly anarchy and
violence that we're seeing.
And so we can't just say,
well, man, it's too late.
We can't hold them accountable.
I think we have to continue
to push our leaders.
Those who on the
one hand are saying,
hey, we're against
censorship by big tech,
but on the other hand are not
backing that up with action
and actually passing legislation
to do something about it.
I think it's because
a lot of them
are getting a lot
of fricking' money,
from the Facebooks
and the Googles
that their fundraisers
that they're doing
at night and saying, oh
yeah, you know, don't worry
I'll just talk about it
but we're not actually
gonna do anything about it.
- Yeah, so to that point,
when you were doing
congressional hearings
on quite literally anything,
did you often feel,
'cause I think a lot of
people now feel this way
that the whole thing
is just theater?
That it's not really--
- So much of it is.
- 'Cause believe
me I watched enough
of the social media
stuff especially,
and it's like there
are guys up there
saying things that I agree
with on the social media front
especially Ted Cruz
kept hitting the stuff
that I really think is right.
And yet I'm going, but
nobody's doing anything.
So you're saying, okay, Jack
from Twitter broke the law
because he lied under
oath about shadow banning
or whatever the
specific thing might be.
But it's like, no
one does anything.
So it's just like this
dog and pony show like,
oh we're all pretending
to go to work
and then we have drinks
together and then that's it.
- Yeah, so much of it is
absolutely political theater
and just for show.
And I think that
there's an opportunity
to hold more leaders
accountable given
how much more access to,
I think this is where
social media can be used
in a positive way,
is to be able to
not allow this kind of stuff
to go unchecked and say, hey,
we're tracking, so, okay,
you're complaining about this,
where's the bill?
Have you talked
to your colleagues
about trying to pass
this legislation?
Are you building support for
it rather than just saying,
okay, well, I'm gonna
put out a statement
and then fundraise off that
statement but not actually
do anything about, and
again this elections thing,
I keep going back to
it because you know,
we're living through it now.
And if all the people
who were complaining
about it now had actually
stepped up as leaders and said,
okay, we have a big
election coming up.
Let's fix these problems
before the election happens.
There's bipartisan agreement
that this is a big issue.
It should have been fixed
before this massive election
in 2020 that we all
knew was coming.
- It's so interesting,
'cause I said on the show
this morning, it's like I'm
completely against violence,
political violence
either way, for sure,
full stop, like no doubt.
And yet the people that are
doing some of this stuff,
who've been called Nazis
and racists who said,
okay, you know, who
see videos online
of what may be election
tampering and all of this stuff.
And they're told, they're not
supposed to see what they see
or they don't see it or
they're conspiracy theorists.
And then we'll get to
more of this in a moment.
But like then we lock
people in their houses
and we don't let
them to go to work.
It's like, that's what I
mean when I said earlier
like it sort of all felt
like it was gonna end up here
in a weird sense that we've
just ramped up the crazy
in so many ways that,
well, people
storming the Capitol,
again, not condoning
it, but it's like,
of course it was gonna happen.
- Well' we have to
understand how we got here
and why we got here.
One of the things that
has so frustrated me
in our politics that I've
seen throughout my time
in Congress is how reactive
our so-called leaders are.
They're not actually
leaders who are exercising
good judgment and foresight
to see, okay, if we do this,
then it's likely to end up
with a certain consequence.
And in situations like this,
I think we'll see a
lot of reactions start
to come out of it
but probably not a whole
lot of introspection to say,
hey, how did we get here
so that we can make sure
that we shift course
that we correct course
and try to get back on
track to prevent this kind
of situation from worsening
or happening again.
That's really where the
leadership comes in,
that we the American
people need,
we've needed all along
and we especially
need at this moment.
- Yeah, so I wanna go into
a couple of the things
'cause you kind of went
out in a blaze of glory,
just like saying everything
that you believe.
At least a whole bunch
of it at the very least
and putting these bills
forward and everything else.
But before we get into
the specifics of that,
I'm curious, do you sense
that someone like you
has a future in the
democratic party?
I get your frustrations
with Democrat, Republican,
left, right and all
that kind of thing.
But do you sense that sort
of the more moderate antiwar,
don't want government doing
absolutely everything Democrat,
does that exist anymore?
- It's becoming more and
more rare in Washington.
I think if, and I don't think
this is a recent phenomena,
but if I look at the
interactions that
I've had with people
throughout my campaign
for president,
the conversations
and the social media
and discussions that are
occurring across the country
with people scratching
their heads at kind of
the crazy things that
Congress is choosing
to prioritize and
take action on.
I think that there are
a majority of people,
maybe most people who are hungry
for some leadership
based on common sense,
and leadership that values
our fundamental freedoms,
as Americans in the
United States of America.
We're not all going
to agree on everything
or maybe even many things,
but I know that we are
better when we are able
to come together and have
honest and real discussions.
Even bringing our
differences to the table
when we are centered and focused
on what we can do together
for the betterment
of our country.
- So do you sense though,
that can happen with kind
of the new wing
of the Democrats?
Like, I don't know if you
were ever in like a sit-down
with AOC and Ilhan and
Rashida and the rest of them.
But do you sense if you came in,
on what I would call your
extremely moderate position
on abortion, that
almost everyone
on the left would
have agreed with,
literally five years ago,
certainly 10 years ago,
where now you'd be
called an evil Republican
or an evil conservative or
worse for having that position.
Do you sense that
they're willing
to have those conversations?
I don't think it's the moderates
that are having the problem
with the conversation.
- I don't.
I don't think that
there is really
even an interest there, sadly.
I think that it's indicative
of a group of people
who are, you're
either all or nothing.
You are either pure
enough in their eyes,
whatever that means
and whatever barometer
with which they're choosing
to measure a person by,
or you're canceled.
I think that's,
and it's a dangerous place
and something that
doesn't represent
the freedom of thought
and the freedom of speech
that we should celebrate
in this country.
- So with that in mind,
I saw an awful lot
of people on Twitter
and although I do say
Twitter is not real life.
I saw a lot of people when
you were campaigning saying,
"man if Tulsi would just
say, she's a Republican,
"she'd have a lot more support."
That in essence you
would be sort of a more
libertarian minded
centrist, Republican,
something like that.
And again, I get it, the two
party thing and all that.
But if you were to have
a political future,
would that make
some sense to you?
- It's not something I've
I've given thought to.
And I don't know.
I think again, I point
to some deeper challenges
that we need to address as
a people and as a country,
and that we need to
look to our leaders
to bring about this deeper
kind of spiritual change,
that's gotta come
from the heart.
Where there's a shift
towards working for
and serving the people,
rather than purely being
motivated by political ambition,
greed, power and all
the selfishness that
frankly is driving
so much of our politics today.
- Yeah can you talk
a little bit more
about how your faith
plays a role in this?
'Cause it's pretty
rare to hear anyone
that's thought of as somewhat
left to talk about faith.
And I know even
during Christmas week
and a few times over the
last couple of months,
you've tweeted out a few things,
a little bit talking
about your faith.
And I do sense we're in
some sort of very odd,
spiritual war right now.
It's not like my
favorite language,
but we are in some thing
where everyone's obsessed
with politics but that's
really just a replacement
for something else.
- You know, this is,
for me personally, my
relationship with God
and my striving daily to
develop my love for God
and to be pleasing
to God, by serving
and taking care of
God's children and
protecting our planet,
this is what motivates
me in my life.
And regardless of the name
with which people
choose to call God
or how one worship
God or whatever,
this is not about religion
or one religion versus another
one, set versus another.
This is to me about the
recognition in a very deep way,
of who we are and seeing past
all of the different labels
that are so often
used to divide us.
And if we see each
other for who we are
that we are all children of God,
regardless of all
of the things that,
again, those labels, those
things that are used to put us
in different boxes,
then we can come from
a place as individuals,
and especially as
leaders in this country
who carry a great
responsibility to make an impact
on people's lives,
positive or negative.
When we come from this
very deep spiritual place
of a recognition of who we
are, then we're motivated
by the most perfect motivation,
which is really truly
to care for each other
and to help each other to
help make that positive impact
from wherever we sit,
whether you're sitting
in the halls of Congress
or sitting as we are in a
conversation here today.
- Good God, I can't
believe they went
with Kamala instead of you.
It's making me...
With that in mind I
think you you tried
to add a little
honesty and decency
and everything that
you just described
in your last few
weeks in Congress.
So I want to go through
a few of the things
that you were
really talking about
and trying to make happen.
Let's talk about
the COVID vaccine.
'Cause you've been
pretty outspoken
about how we've really butchered
some of what we're doing here,
in terms of the rollout.
- This may shock people
but I really strongly
have been pushing our CDC and
their advisory committees,
as well as our state
leadership here in Hawaii,
leaders across the country
to make their decisions
based on medical science.
About who should
receive this vaccine,
what's the priority,
given the limited amount
of vaccine available, who
needs to receive it first?
If you look at medical
science, you would find
that based on the, all of the
trials that have been done
it has been
scientifically established
that this vaccine is effective
in preventing serious
health complications
from COVID and even death.
It has not been
scientifically established
that this vaccine is effective
in stopping this virus
from being transmitted
from one person to another.
So if you look at
both of those facts
that have been
scientifically established,
you would draw the conclusion
that the first priority
of people who should
get this vaccine
are our frontline healthcare
workers and elderly Americans.
Those who are over
65 years of age,
and who have been proven
throughout this entire pandemic
are many, many times
more likely to die,
if they get this virus
than those who are
younger and healthy.
Unfortunately the
recommendations
that are coming out
of the CDC do not reflect
what has been
established by science.
And this is the warning
that I'm calling out.
So what is that?
What is going on in the CDC?
- What they're recommending
essentially is they have,
they're making politically
driven decisions
that are essentially
putting the lives
of elderly American
seniors at risk.
Where they're saying,
okay, well, yes frontline
healthcare workers
are getting it first as
they should right now.
But those who are getting
it next are people
who they deem as
essential workers.
Which is about 87
million Americans.
And those who fall
under everything from
people who are working
at the grocery store,
people who are manning
the cash register
at a liquor store, to lawyers,
to people working in the
media, to people working
in transportation,
constructions, corrections.
There's essentially a
laundry list of people
who they have deemed as
essential workers of any age,
who they're saying should
either get the vaccine
before our seniors,
or who are seniors
need to compete with,
in order to get this vaccine.
And this is what is,
it's just mind boggling because
this is coming from people
who claim to be medical experts,
but they're not making their
decisions based on science.
They're instead making
politically motivated decisions.
- Where do you fall
generally on lockdowns
and the rest of it?
I mean, you know, we're
coming up unbelievably
on basically almost a year.
I mean, it's been
about 10 months already
of sort of lockdowns,
masks, the whole thing.
We were told two weeks
to flatten the curve.
And now we're being told,
oh, maybe a hundred-day,
federal mask mandate.
I'm in California where
everything is locked down.
I mean, the main
street I live off of,
it looks like a ghost town.
I mean, it genuinely
looks like a ghost town.
Do you believe this should
have been left to the States?
And are you kind of shocked at
how it's now 10 months later
and we kind of forget
where we started from?
- I mean, there's no question
that this is a major
public health issue given,
not only how infectious
this virus is
but also the recent mutation
that we've seen occur
in the UK and other places.
And now I think Colorado
has gotten the first few
of an even more infectious
version of COVID.
So I think that they're,
the baseline standard
of public health precautions
do need to be taken,
which you know it is.
Wear a mask, protect
yourself, protect others
and wash your hands
and socially distance.
The lack of a national strategy
with regards to testing
has worsened the situation
where still as we sit here today
it is incredibly
difficult to get a test.
If you test more
frequently and more people,
then you have the
ability for people to act
on that information and
take precautions themselves.
There's no reason
why we shouldn't have
these capabilities
deployed all across the country.
There's no reason
why we shouldn't have
medical grade masks
available to every American,
which are actually most
effective versus the cloth masks
that so many people
are forced to use
because they can't
get medical masks.
And then the issue with
the nonsensical decisions
that a lot of state and
local leaders are making
for example, in California,
I saw, I think it's a viral
video at this point where this
guy is out paddle boarding
in the water by himself, then
was apprehended by police
both in the water and on land.
How does that make any sense?
we had here locally there was
a decision made for a while.
Like, no one's allowed
to go outdoors.
No one is allowed to leave
your home, unless for,
you're going to the doctor,
you're going to
the grocery store.
But we know that people
who are able to get out
of the sunshine--
- How is the weather
in Hawaii, again?
Usually nice, pretty okay.
- Pretty sunny, pretty sunny.
Which we know is better for
increasing your immunity.
Exercise is good for you.
They said, okay,
we'll let people out,
but like, we'll, open
up the hikes again,
but you can only go by yourself.
You can't go with anybody,
like, okay so I can't go
hiking with my husband?
We live together.
And how safe is
it for one person
to go out on a hike in the
mountains by themselves.
But I mean, it's just,
there's so many
different examples of
of really nonsensical
decisions that again have not
been made based on science
and how best to help
protect our communities
and protect people's
health and wellbeing.
And the more, and then of course
the last I'll mention is how
we are all told nationally
by these so-called
medical experts
that gathering in
large groups of people
creates a great harm
and a great risk.
But all of a sudden, if
there's a mass gathering
for a political purpose that
these experts agree with
then it's okay.
And it's fine.
And so there's no surprise
in my mind why so many people
are throwing like the BS flag
on the field and saying, you
know, I don't trust you guys.
I don't trust you guys.
How can we trust what you
are telling us is true?
And that this will actually
help protect our neighbors
and friends and community?
When there's no consistency.
And these decisions
are not being made
based on proven medical science.
- What do you think just
sort of philosophically
about lockdowns in general?
I mean, they haven't
been proven to work.
California is clearly
an example of that.
I spent last week in Florida
where everything was open
and the numbers are actually
less and people are out there
and they're living their lives.
But philosophically just
sort of the amount of people
that we've just put out of work
and we know depression is up
and alcoholism is up
and drug use is up
and all of this stuff,
it's almost like people
are just kind of forgetting
what freedom is like you really,
within 10 months you can
completely forget it.
- Yeah, I think that there's,
I don't think that
one can say yes
lockdowns or no lockdowns
as a broad statement.
I think that there are
certain things that could
and should be done in
a public health crisis,
like the one that we are seeing
to try to contain a virus
like this, but again, those
decisions should be made based
on the science and what we
know will be most effective.
I think one of the
ineffective things
that we've seen occur is
how big box retailers,
for example have been allowed
to remain completely open
and conducting their
business as per usual
with large numbers of
people going in and out
every single day.
And yet, you know, the
small mom and pop shop
on the corner has been
forced to shut down
because they are
not essential again.
How are you choosing who is
essential and non-essential?
Who gets to stay open
and who gets to close.
And frankly, it's been
the biggest corporations
who have benefited the
most, who've been allowed
to stay open throughout
this pandemic.
Whereas the small
businesses, the restaurants
and small shops in
our communities have
not been allowed
to open their doors.
Again, points to politically
motivated decisions
rather than decisions
made in the best interest
of the people.
- Do you think we ever get back
to something that will feel
like the good old days
of February of last year?
Meaning that even if
tomorrow, they said, okay
we cured this thing.
Everyone's got the
vaccine, we're good.
That just because of sort of
what you talked before this
we were in sort of
an information war.
People are so
untrustworthy of sources.
That people just either
won't go out or they,
if you were a businessman,
how would you say, okay,
I'm gonna open a restaurant now,
like you would, it's hard.
90% of restaurants I think
fail in the first year anyway.
Like how would you
take the risk to go out
and do that stuff?
Like it seems to me that
the normal people are like,
oh we'll get back to normal.
I don't think so.
- A friend of mine recently
had the guts to open
a restaurant just a
few months ago there
in Southern California.
And I've been keeping
in touch with him.
They've had to shut
down a couple of times
because of someone came
in and had tested positive
and had to go through all
of the things to make sure
that everyone was okay.
But they're losing something
like $15,000 a day,
just to keep the doors open
and they're trying
to persevere through.
And I know there's so
many others who are
either doing the same or
who have not been able
to sustain that kind of loss.
It's hard to say at this
point, I think that,
even going beyond what
you're talking about
just the basic level of
consciousness now about hygiene
and health and other
things are changing the way
that we will all view,
live our lives and the
kinds of things that we do.
I think that, I think some
of the things that we've seen
in Asia where people wear masks
a lot more just by choice.
I think that's something
we'll probably see
especially for those who travel.
I know I was wearing
masks on airplanes
before this pandemic began,
just because it's like,
you don't know
who's on the plane,
there's a lot of sick people
and I don't want to get sick.
- You mean, you were wearing
masks before it was cool?
- I will wear that
badge with pride.
- All right, so let's
jump through a couple
of the other things that you did
because I think it
gets to my point
that there was a moderate
sane Democrat at one point.
And unfortunately she's
not in Congress anymore.
They just passed this
gendered language situation
in the house of representatives.
They're removing
gendered language
which Nancy Pelosi
pushed through.
Although, hilariously, I think
it's still in her Twitter bio
that she's a mother
and a grandmother
which are both gendered terms.
But they want,
in essence they're taking
gender terms should not be used
in the house of
representatives anymore.
And you were trying at least
to get that to not happen.
- Yeah, I had a hard
time believing it
when I actually, I need to go
and actually read
the legislation.
I went in and read it.
And it did just that
to somehow believe
that it is a good thing
to remove all references
of mother and father,
brother, and sister,
son and daughter from
essentially the administration
of the house from the
legislative rules.
It makes, it not only
does it not make sense.
It is a dangerous step
towards undermining,
who we are and the
existence of men and women.
And this is where I see
such great hypocrisy
is that this is coming
from so many people
who proudly proclaim
that they are champions
of rights for women.
How can you claim that while
simultaneously taking steps
to undermine the fact that
a biological woman exists?
And again like we can
take this back directly
to Science and Biology,
and this is something
that more people
should be talking about
and not running away from.
- But even putting aside
like the specifics of it,
just the fact that
there's so much going on
in the country right now,
and that any legislator
actually spent 10 seconds
crafting this nonsense,
while there's so much more
important stuff to deal with.
That as someone in in Congress
must have drove you crazy.
'Cause I'm sure you
saw all sorts of things
like this over the years.
- You know, I
introduced a resolution,
one of the bills that I
introduced right before I left
with Congressman Green, a
Republican and a fellow veteran
that basically said,
hey, we as Congress need
to take action to make sure
that the CDC immediately starts
to make sure this
vaccine is available
to our elderly Americans who
are dying at higher rates
than anyone else from COVID.
If there's a first
act that Congress,
this new Congress could
have and should have taken,
it should have been that.
By recognizing that
people's lives are at stake
and we have the
opportunity potentially
to help save people's lives.
How about that be getting
your priorities straight
and putting the lives
of the American people,
our elders our moms and
dads and grandparents first.
What do you think
Pelosi would say,
if she was watching this right
now, if she's sitting next
to you right now,
and you said to her,
well, why did you bother
doing this right now?
What do you think she would say?
- I don't know, to be honest.
I don't know what she would say.
I don't know.
I don't know, but the
fact that this action
was not an obvious one to take,
coming right out of the gate,
coming out of the new year,
where every single day
people are concerned
about their parents
and grandparents
and when they can
get the vaccine,
so they can not be
imprisoned in their homes,
they can go out, they
can go to the doctor
they can go and see and spend
time with their families.
The fact that that was not
the obvious first choice
I think really says it all.
- Yeah, well, it's
sort of a perfect segue
because you also tried to put
forth this trans athlete bill.
And for some reason,
the trans issue
and particularly
related to sports
this has become like
the third rail thing.
You can't touch it.
If you even say
anything remotely close
to what you just said
that there are
biological differences
between men and women you'll
be called to transphobia
and everything else.
But you put forth a built
to in effect, say yes,
there are some differences
and we have to acknowledge it.
- And for those who
actually read the bill
and it's not that long,
I know this is usually a thing.
People are like, oh,
this bill does this.
Actually just read it.
It's pretty simple and very
direct and straightforward.
And it basically, it doesn't
mention trans people at all.
It is called the Protect
Women's Sports Act.
I introduced it with
my Republican friend,
Markwayne Mullin who
has three little girls
who love to wrestle the,
the oldest Laura's 12,
the younger twins are 10.
They all love to wrestle and
they're really good at it.
And he recognizes that it
would be neither fair nor safe
for his little girls to
go and compete on a mat
against the biological boy.
There are physiological
differences that exist
between boys and girls
and men and women.
And when you look to, and
this is what our bill does,
it clarifies upholds and
strengthens title nine
which was enacted in 1972,
out of that recognition
that there are biological
and physiological distinctions
between boys and girls,
men and women.
And title nine ensures
that girls and women
are able to play in sports
and compete in sports
on a level playing field.
Title nine is being undermined
and weakened in some areas,
as States are
interpreting what it does
in very different ways.
And as a result, as we've seen
in places like Connecticut,
you have girls who are,
they're about to graduate
from high school.
They're vying for
scholarships to college
and losing in track
and field competitions
because they have all of
a sudden now been faced
with a competitor who has
a very direct physiological
advantage as a biological male.
And they're seeing
their scholarship hopes
and dreams be taken
away from them.
And so this really just says,
hey, this is about making sure
that all of those opportunities
that were provided to women
and girls, because
title nine was in place,
are allowed to continue for
this generation and the next.
It doesn't discriminate
against anyone.
It just simply says, if
you're a biological female
you shouldn't be
forced to compete
in sports against
the biological male.
- Do you want to
make any comments
about trans people before
the haters get in here?
Because I know you have no
problem with trans people
but I know that they'll
hear what you just said
and say she's a transphobe.
So do you want to just
just clean it up for them
before they get to it?
- I think that people are
allowed and free to be able
to make their own choices
and live in this country
as Americans and be treated
justly under the laws
as we all are.
If you again, look
at my legislation
you'll recognize that
this very simply points
to biological differences
between men and women
and upholds the incredible
game-changing and life-changing
opportunities that
title nine created back
in the early seventies.
- All right so the next
one that you went for
because you really just
pulled out all the stops
on your way out the door.
You tried to pass
an abortion bill
and we have a similar,
we talked about abortion last
time you were on the show
and we have a
similar stance on it.
My position before I wrote
my book was 20 weeks.
Because at that point, we know
that the fetus can feel pain.
Now there's actually
a little evidence
that it's closer to 18 weeks.
But then in my book, I took
the first trimester position
which is about 12
weeks in effect.
And I talk about, I concede
that I believe it's a life.
I tried to talk about
as many of the moral
and philosophical
and religious issues
and all of those things.
I think, you know
that David and I
are in the midst of
surrogacy right now.
So I'm like well aware
of all of the stuff
related to this, right?
You put forth a bill
that, as I said earlier
was the democratic
position for pretty much
the last three decades or so,
but is not the democratic
position anymore.
So can you lay it out for us?
- Sure it is,
I introduced two bills.
One is the Late Term
Abortion Ban Act.
And the other is the Born
Alive Survivors Protection Act.
There were similar
pieces of legislation
that were introduced
previously in Congress,
that had some minor
issues with the bill
that I felt that I needed
to vote against it.
For example, the Late
Term Abortion Act,
there had been a similar bill
that was introduced previously
that provided an exception
to the bill if the life of
the mother was at stake,
but it did not allow
for any exception
if there were severe
and irreversible
health and physical consequences
at stake for the mother.
So the bill that I introduced,
so I felt that I had to
oppose it at that time
because it did not
provide that exception.
The bill that I introduced
included that essentially,
but was mostly the
same as the other bill.
And the born alive for
babies who are born alive
even after an
attempted abortion,
there are laws in place
that should be strengthened
to make sure that any doctor
and healthcare provider
in that situation must
do all that they can
to save that baby's life,
no matter how that baby
got to that situation.
Just as they would be
required to do under law
for a baby that was
born prematurely,
maybe at that same age.
To me these are bills
that every American
frankly should support.
- Right, so I could
get not supporting it
if you were completely
against abortion
because you just wouldn't
want those bills to exist.
But for the group
of people that have,
some gray area there,
what's your actual
position on the cutoff
of your first trimester
also, if I'm not mistaken?
- The bill is 20 weeks.
It is modeled after,
as you mentioned,
there's been a lot of
science that's based around
when the baby can
start to feel pain.
And that's what the
bill is based on.
- Yeah do you find
that even on abortion
that it's easier in an odd
way to talk to Republicans?
I think the average Republican
or conservative let's say
is gonna disagree
with you on this.
They absolutely disagree
with me on this.
The amount of letters
that I got saying,
Dave I loved your book.
You're wrong on
abortion, but it's okay.
But we can agree to disagree.
Do you find that even people
who completely disagree
with you on this, on the right
are still willing to
talk to you about it?
Where to take that 20-week
position on the left,
is pretty much
impossible these days.
- Yeah which is unfortunate.
I mean, for me personally,
I am personally pro-life.
I would never make that
choice to have an abortion.
It's often one of the
most difficult decisions
that any woman may
make in her life.
And it really comes down to,
what role does the government
have to play into this?
And so this is a much,
much bigger topic
that we as Americans should
come together and talk about
and discuss because
when you implement laws,
there are consequences that come
with those laws and
there's a country,
I believe it might've, I
think it was Argentina.
Might be mistaken, it was
a South American country.
That for example,
had very strict laws
in place where they ended
up actually arresting women
who had had miscarriages
because it was a violation
of their anti-abortion laws.
So we've gotta go
through this question,
morally as a society and the
decision that people are making
for themselves and the
impacts of that personally,
but also what role government
should have in this
incredibly personal decision
that a woman may make for
herself and her family.
So I've seen just going
back to your question,
yeah, I mean,
there are Democrats
and people who consider
themselves progressives
who really believe that there
should be no restrictions
whatsoever on abortion.
I completely disagree with that.
I think that to a
certain point women need
to be able to make this
decision for themselves,
but there should be very
clear restrictions in place.
And that we as a society,
should come together
to find ways to make it so
that this is a rare decision.
That is put in place.
And unfortunately,
that's not something
that is being pushed,
especially by Democrats.
- Yeah, and that's so
unfortunate because it's like,
man, if you guys would
just show us a little
of that gray area, you
could still keep people.
But I always, I've debated
abortion with plenty of pro-life
people on my show, Ben
Shapiro and Dennis Prager
and a whole bunch of others.
And I always say
to them at the end,
you know you guys make
compelling arguments,
but in a weird way it's
the craziness of the left
that has made me
slightly more pro-life.
Because if you're gonna tell
me, you can have an abortion
at eight months, I
just can't get there.
- No, I agree.
- Yeah, let's do a little
bit of a future stuff
before we let you go.
So first we'll do some
quick political stuff
then I want to do
some personal stuff.
So, all right.
It does look like Joe Biden
will be the president,
Kamala Harris will
be vice president.
Do you sense despite everything
we've talked about here
and obviously what's
unfolding in DC right now,
that this idea of healing,
I know you want it to happen
but you know, we're being
told now it's the time to heal
and all of this stuff.
Do you sense that we're
really going to get there?
Or is it just kinda,
a little bit of lip
service for now?
- I think the jury is
still out right now.
Again, I very much hope
that we see a major shift
in our leadership, and yes the
tone that the president sets
is very important, but
it's gotta be bigger
and more far reaching than that.
So, we'll see what
happens there.
We'll see what happens through
the nomination process,
the kinds of people
that we've seen,
Biden choose as his nominees
to serve in his cabinet.
To me, some of the
problems that I see
very directly are that
many of them represent
the same kind of corruption,
legal corruption in Washington,
that we've seen for a long time.
Where you have people who rotate
through this revolving door
of working in government,
then you go work as a lobbyist,
then you go get money
from a defense contractor,
then you go back in and work
in the department of defense.
And this is what we see in
who he's nominated to serve
as secretary of defense.
He was yanked off
the board of Raytheon
to go and now be the nominee
for secretary of defense.
You see this with the
secretary of state nominee,
Tony Blinken, who's just
made a whole bunch of money
from defense contractors
in the time between
the Biden administration, the
Obama administration and now.
What to speak of the policies
that a lot of these folks
represent which are really
centered around looking
at their track records,
continuing these
costly warmongering
regime change interventions
that have proven
to be incredibly
destructive and costly.
Both for us here
in this country,
our troops, our people,
as well as the people
in the countries where
these Wars have been waged.
And that's something that's
of serious concern to me.
And again something that
I'm going to continue
to be very vocal on trying
to shift our country's policy
and into one that actually
works best for our country
the American people, and
for peace and security.
- I think what you just
said there is that the swamp
is real in effect.
When people talk
about the swamp,
this rotating group of
people that come in and out
and never really kind
of do much of anything.
All right, so that's
the political part.
But what about for
you personally?
Because I know people would love
to have you back in politics.
I know you want to
take a little break
and do some other things.
What's going on with Tulsi?
- I'm in Hawaii right now.
I am gonna go surfing
hopefully in a few hours.
Yeah, look, I don't
know specifically yet,
but I do know that I am
going to be continuing
to be a strong voice
and a strong advocate
for a lot of these issues
that we're talking about
that really center
around upholding our
fundamental freedoms
as Americans in this country
that are under threat,
that we cannot take for granted.
Continuing to push
for an advocate
for common sense
policies and solutions.
And frankly, just
conversations where we can
bring people together who
may have different views
and backgrounds and
have a sincere exchange
of ideas based on respect.
In that spirit of Aloha of
really caring for each other
and caring for the
future of this country
and the world for that matter.
- That feels like a
good ending to me.
What about you?
- I think so, I think so.
There's no better way to close,
open and close a
conversation than Aloha.
- There you go.
All right, well, it
was good seeing you
or whatever these
digital things are.
I hope I'm gonna work on
getting out to Hawaii.
I do need a little
escape from California,
so I'm gonna work on that.
- I think so.
- But good luck
with everything--
- You let me know,
we'll go out in the water.
- You know, I've
only surfed once,
so you're gonna
have some serious,
you got some teaching skills.
I know you do.
- It's okay.
I do, I do.
You'll be in good
hands, trust me.
- I do have a torn, I have
a torn ACL in my knee,
but that's a separate issue.
- You'll be fine.
- All right, Tulsi thanks
so much for doing this.
- Thank you, Dave.
- And I look forward
to seeing what's next.
- Thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell.